Điều bbc của anh em em ba thăm em một cho biết đã ăn gọi thứ xin lỗi cả nhân tới tổng thủng trường năng tròm
vì các biên tập về chân cả ai trong buộc phim tài liệu phát sống trước cuộc mộ cửa của năng hàng hình hãy tư
nhưng khẳng định không có cơ sở pháp đi cho các cạo buộc phía bàng mà phía đôi gủ gủ gủng tròm đưa ra
buộc phía phát trong truy trình phát nụ ra mà đã gái máu đoạn khăn nhau trong bà phát biểu ngày một sau thăm một lăm hàng hình hãy mốt của ông trăm
tạo cảm giác ông đang kêu gọi bà lực khi người ủng hộ tình công đôi kẹp tổng
lật sự của tổng thủ đoạn trăm đe dọa kẹp bbc đoạn bối thường tới một tỷ đoạn Mỹ nhớ đại không giúp phía
và bối thử thạch tại chính bà quy tỉnh trong bất thử xin lỗi dưới tệ nhạch trắng
chủ tình bbc xa miше tự nhận trước trình là xa sóo trọng phát đoạn
nông thời nói đại không có kể phát lại nội dùng này bbc cũng đa xem xét tắt cạo buộc mới lên quan tự trường trình rius này
được bảo tên lệ grop đưa ra buộc đại bbc xo hơn vào cuộc khung hạn nghiêm trọng nhất trong
nhật thực ký sau khi tổng giống đốc tìm đầy bý và lãnh đạo mạng tý tức đế bộ rà trời nếc
tự trực vì áp lực giữa lên quan đến cạo buộc thêm lạnh trong bối cảnh đại
cua ra anh chưa có lãnh đạo trường trực thủ tường anh kêu stam mơ khọng định chính phủ vấn đúng
hộ bbc mạnh mẽ và đập lập